what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
a video by the roommates podcast titles
nice guys must learn the truth about
women i always find it really
interesting to see what like the dating
gurus say
about like dating girls so just like as
a girl
so let me know in the comments what i
should react to next don't forget to
like
comment and subscribe especially
subscribe
uh my next goal is 20 000 subscribers
and yeah okay let's start this all day
long they're making decisions they're
doing what how does this get done blah
blah
and then they come home or they're with
us and we go what do you want to do it's
like they got to make one more decision
so i tell guys the greatest gift that
you can give to
to your woman to a relationship is to
set the tone and lead that's not to try
to get her to do anything or control her
it's to say here's what i would like
what do you think
yeah that even that little that little
snippet
yeah i'd agree with that
here's something i say to men whatever
the male brain
thinks a woman can do for him it's wrong
it's wrong whatever we meant through
through
just social mythology of
beginning with our mothers to television
to movies
to love songs to whatever we think a
woman is going to do
for us is wrong and because she can't
you know the the majority of our needs
have to be met
by men we're just not going to get them
met
but what men do is they put everything
in one
basket so to speak and go i'll go get a
woman and then she'll
she'll meet all my knees she'll complete
me and and she can't
she doesn't want to but she can't and
and then when she
doesn't you know we're hurt either like
you know
we're trying to get her to fill our
basket fill our bucket up
and she can't do it and so what most
nice guys are doing is
we get into this pleaser mode trying to
make her happy
trying to do everything right and we
leave her in charge
of everything um i i think one of the
biggest pieces now
i i have to be really clear about this
because i talk with men about setting
the tone and leading
in their relationship and and when i
when i talk about that a lot of times
guys will say all right all right dr
glover i know when you say take control
and i go no
i never use the word control i don't say
control your relationship or control
your woman or control any
yeah and that distinction is very like
it's very
important but i think i know where he's
going with this control you
to the best of your ability no setting
the tone and leading
means you have a plan you know where
you're going
you know what excites you you know what
you're passionate about
and you invite your woman to come join
you in that space
and this is why i always say like it's
really
not about money for girls it's about
having a plan
and ambition which people really
confused with money because someone
could win the lottery
and they wouldn't be more attractive to
women but ambition and drive that's
what's attractive
and and i would say that a woman can't
follow where a man doesn't lead and
you know again i know that's contrary to
all the vibe we hear oh you know about
you know about women being independent
not needing a man
but no i keep hearing over and over
again the biggest complaint that women
have about men
is because the guy thinks well she wants
to make all the decisions
he leaves them all up to her and the
woman feels burdened by that
exactly i yeah oh my gosh
yeah that's very true years ago i was
got done
i was actually taught a a small class um
on on dating and a bunch of the guys
wanted to go out and get a bite so we
went to a restaurant that i used to hang
out in quite a bit when i was a single
guy
and um and i knew all the waiters and
waitresses and one of the waitresses
came by and her name was jessica
and i and in front of this group of guys
i said jessica i want to ask you a
question
i knew she was single and i said how do
you like it when the guy you're dating
or the guy you're
with leaves all the decisions up to you
says
what do you want to do tonight where do
you want to go what do you want to eat
and she just looked at me she goes i
hate it yeah
[Music]
yeah oh my gosh that's so funny
that was it i hate it and then took our
order left i just looked at all the guys
they hate it they feel burdened we think
we're being nice so what do you want
dear what do you want to watch
what do you want to eat and they just
feel burdened
you know again if they have a career i
mean all day long they're making
decisions they're doing what
yeah because as like it's just nice to
have someone like
have like just to not have to make
another decision like it's very
attractive how does this get done
and then they come home or they're with
us and we go what do you want to do it's
like they got to make one more decision
so i tell guys the greatest gift that
you can give to
to your woman to a relationship is to
set the tone and lead that's not to try
to get her to do anything
or control her it's to say here's what
i would like what do you think you know
come join me
and if she says well i'd really rather
do this you can have a negotiation from
there it's not about you getting your
way at anything
it's just having a plan it's just
getting the ball rolling
now in my life i
i my wife and i were sitting outside
i'm i'm on my third marriage we were
sitting outside last night we taking the
dog for a walk and she said
are we coming up on four years or five
years our anniversary's in
in november and i said no we've been
married four and a half years
and she was like really and um and so
we're just kind of talking a little bit
about
about the marriage and she says i i
didn't see any
any of this coming you know 10 years ago
i didn't see my life being this way
you know we we have a nice home we can
travel
we got this really cool dog her kids are
getting a good education
she was she was a poor single mom 10
years ago
and but my point is here
i'd be interested to know what attracted
him to her because
you always hear about how like guys
don't like especially in the dating guru
space how guys like don't want to date
single moms but he just
married one is it i'm living life on my
terms
i love what i do i'm making a difference
in the world i
can make good enough money doing it i'm
happy doing i'm 65
most men retire at my age i don't i
don't even know what that looked like i
i still have so many things i want to
get done so many interviews i still need
to do
and and you know i'm not a dominant
controlling person
at all but i live life on my terms
and and i'll say to my wife you want to
go do this you want to go do that you
want to go eat here
you want you don't want uh i'm thinking
about buying this car what do you think
you always have a plan yeah and she just
you know
she'll give me her wisdom and her
insight on it but it's usually it's kind
of like
let's go let's do it or if i say hey i
think we need this
you know we finally decided to get a dog
about a year ago
she went out and found the dog and now
we've got this amazing
pit bull pup that's about a year old and
most women
aren't super opinionated like they don't
really care
but when you have someone like suggest
something to you
and you feel like your input is like
heard if you do
want to do something else or what
whatever like i could see what he's
teaching guys that makes sense
you know she she could we're a team we
get things done
but it's usually me that starts the ball
rolling
and i mean when we first met and got
serious and got involved
you know i said i said i don't know if i
want to live here in mexico all my life
i said i like a lot of things here but i
i might want to live somewhere else and
she said
wherever you go i'll follow just don't
ask me to leave my kids and i go i would
never do that
i'm not going to ask you to leave your
kids and she goes no you you decide
there's a better place for us to go live
i'm with you
so and again my wife is not a passive
person
she grew up eight out of ten kids in in
poverty in guadalajara mexico
she's a tough woman um she works out in
our gym
two hours every day she's done my ties
she can out squat me
she's a tough woman and so for her to
say you know
you know wherever you lead i'm there
with you
and i'll always be looking out for her
best interest she knows that i won't
ever make a unilateral decision
that doesn't consider what's good for
her and that's why character is so
important when you are choosing someone
to date because if you're going to
follow someone you want to make sure
that they have the character
to make decisions that are not only in
their best interests but yours
too well so that's that's the gift i
think we men can bring
is if we know where we're going in life
and the way david davis says it
he tells women you know decide where you
want to go find a man who's trained is
going that direction and get on it
now and i know i know that you know
again the feminists might not like that
model
but yeah find a man whose life is going
in a way
that you honor and that you think's
amazing and go
be a part of that go team up with him
yeah
no that's powerful i and and i had this
quote that came to me recently i i said
it's interesting that
when a woman calls a man daddy
it's a turn on but when a man calls his
woman mommy to turn off
oh why did he say that ah why did he say
that i
just made me feel weird so
i think it's very i tell guys all the
time like you said
life is a dance and for most women
no matter how masculine confident
competent they are
most women and you like reference
because you're in mexico most women will
not be happy
leading the salsa dance from the whole
night
most women no matter how skilled she is
no matter how intelligent she is
she does not want to lead the dance she
wants a competent
confident masculine leader to lead her
in the dance
and so i think it's so important like
you said like and
um decisiveness uh initiative
proactivity all these things are so
important that
every single man understands
because like you said so many guys they
they try to
because i i really believe it goes back
to the single motherhood crisis
the the they've been so used to being
their moms
surrogate husbands they really have not
learned how to cut the emotional
umbilical cord
and become a man on his own and like you
said when you are a man
who builds his life who builds his
kingdom who's walking passionately and
and with integrity and has direction and
purpose
you will find that the right kind and
caliber of woman
will see you and and willingly want to
take part
in your dance but but something else
that you said
and i and you don't have to share if you
don't want to and i'm curious about this
because you said that
you started writing the book while
you're in your second marriage
and uh recently you said four and a half
years ago you entered into your third
marriage so
have you ever noticed how the majority
of relationship
gurus have been married two or three
times i mean
maybe they learn stuff along the way and
that's why they give advice i totally
get that
but it's just something i've noticed
like they've all been married
to three times so um your your second
marriage ended
or aren't married at all after this book
came out
and as you began to go on your masculine
journey so
was it something in which as you became
more masculine and competent and
confident um
it was it began to create strains on
your relationship you don't have to
share if you don't want to but i'm
wondering
i loved it there's nothing about me
that's not
out there um now that's a good question
and people
do ask me that one to say well you know
robert you know you've got a phd in
marriage and family therapy you're a
marriage therapist
you know you've been married three times
you know we have this idea
that you know if you get married and if
you don't stay married there's
there's a failure in there of some sort
um
kind of like there's it's more you know
it's more complicated than
than that i mean i'm sorry but think
about it
what would you rather have a couple
that's been married for
40 years or your third marriage of five
years what
what would seem more successful i'm just
saying but here's
what happened is that my second wife who
i wrote was married to when i wrote no
more mr nice guy the one that got me
into therapy
and into improvement she was the big
stick upside my head
and and i'm grateful for her we're
talking today because of her
and until the day i die i'll be grateful
for for that woman
and she she challenged me in so many
ways i
she was intuitive she was sharp she
wouldn't ever let me off the hook
of any of my nice guy behaviors and
without going into detail
she had plenty of her own stuff and we
went to a ton of therapy
she calculated at some point she loved
going to therapy
at some point she said you know i think
between us we've spent probably
a hundred thousand dollars on therapy
wow we could have had a few mercedes for
that
and and i now jokingly say i i think
that was probably 85
000 too much to figure out our marriage
wasn't going to work
i think 15 grand is enough to find out
if a marriage is going to work or not
and so what happened is actually we
split about about
six eight months before the print
edition of no more mr nice guy came out
and um what i realized why
why we split is that i realized i'd made
significant changes
and i knew when i wrote the book that
there was one big piece i wasn't done
with yet
and that was i knew i was still
tolerating too many things in a
relationship
and and
what what actually happened why our
relationship how we broke up she got mad
at me about something
and said i want you to move out and you
know that was not an uncommon thing
and um i said okay and i did and about
two weeks later said i i
i changed my mind i want you to move
back and i said i ain't coming back
you know this is hard enough getting out
and i'm not coming back damn
what i realized is that she was
essential for a lot of my personal
growth
but i'd outgrown that need and
she had not outgrown those things that
were still
uh detrimental to our relationship
and so to this day i love her to death
i'm grateful for her i after being
married to her i then went through a
period
about 12 years of living alone and
learning how to be
live alone be on my own how to be a
single guy out of date i ended up
writing a book
because i learned how to date i wrote a
book about that
and had some great relationships and
learned a lot and grew a lot
and um and they said you know my wife
and i
i think we met about six six maybe
almost
seven years ago and uh we've been
married about four and a half years
and um i wasn't looking i wasn't looking
to get married
when looking for anything in particular
like so many good things in life she
found me
and um after a period of time i realized
this is too good to
walk away from and so that's that's what
got that's a short version of what got
me to where i am today
yeah and it's fascinating because that's
what i i
i believe what what you what you're
going to tell me because what i've seen
happen so often is when guys have these
nice guy
tendencies um and when guys haven't
fully tapped into the masculinity
they usually get a woman who's usually
more masculine than him
right and they usually find a woman who
wants to be in charge who's used to
being um
you know the leader who's not happy
being the leader right
and that usually doesn't like work long
term but then but then
the fundamental change what i've
realized is it's kind of
i call the mommy effect right that when
your mom gives birth to you you will
always be your baby
no matter how tall you are how big your
muscles are no matter how much money you
have
she always views you as her baby because
she wiped her diaper because she know
she fed you because she
burped you you will always be mommy's
baby so when when you end up be
entering into a relationship where a
woman is now taking that masculine
motherly role to take care of you she
now views you
as her baby so then eventually when nice
guys you know read your books or find my
content
and they begin to build themselves up
tap into the masculinity
and want to now leave provocative leave
passionately but not just lead past lead
they also want to set boundaries
and no longer tolerate unhealth what
they realize is now that woman
is unable to now submit to him
unable to follow him because she views
him as that baby
and she is now conditioned to always
being in charge
and having her way so when the man
establishes boundary
now there be though two become
incongruent so
i wanted you to share that because i
want some of the guys to realize that
when you begin to level up and become
the best version yourself especially if
you are currently
in an unhealthy relationship but you
haven't happened to your masculinity
you may outgrow the woman that you're
with
and it's okay and so i just i really
appreciate you sharing that because i
see that happen
with so many men in my community
yeah i would say that
this stuff is actually pretty helpful
it's a lot more like pg
um and more how do i put it like
nice then a lot of the dating advice i
see for guys
uh no i think girls definitely want to
be with someone that's like
makes decisions and they can like give
their input i would say that's really
attractive
and same with like they're telling guys
to like build up find your purpose
yeah that's all pretty good advice let
me know in the comments what you think
if there's anything they got right
got wrong don't forget to like comment
and subscribe
especially subscribe i will talk to you
guys next time